i like all of these
figurines that's pretty cool is that
thanos it is yes
my father i think
this entire day was worth it just for
that statement
so uh one of the things about this is
that uh every time you make an action
everything i believe all the movies
you've made that involve
action have always been with also men
what i loved about this is it's just a
group of kick-ass women
working together uh can you sort of talk
i mean i'm assuming that was like your
immediate reason for saying yes to this
project
it was definitely one of the reasons
because it's just quite rare to have
like a whole group of women
normally there's some but the majority
are
men and so to get to work with like an
incredible group of actresses
and they weren't even cast yet so only
lena was cast and that was enough to
obviously make me say yes but then
when i heard who the other actresses
were gonna be i was like this is
the jackpot brilliant
i i completely agree uh as i was
watching it i was thinking to myself
i can't imagine what it was like in
between takes getting to hang out with
this cast
yeah it was i was pretty starstruck to
be honest so i think i was trying to
play it cool i don't know i must have
been coming off weird
but no we had a really good time i mean
you know we had wine
when we had down time and and me and
lena were just making
ridiculous videos for instagram
constantly to the point where they were
like please stop
you're making too much noise and we're
trying to shoot a movie
uh before i run out of time with you
even though i have a lot of time um i
loved in the third act that slow motion
tracking shot
that one er it's so badass
isn't it yeah it's it i mean that that's
reason enough
just to watch the movie is just for that
shot and it's so cool
can you sort of talk about filming that
shot because that could not have been
easy
so yeah that shot actually i think that
mainly involves i didn't have the heavy
lifting in that one
so that was kind of all on the ladies
and i don't know how they managed to
pull that off
as quickly as they did because i believe
that was the first thing they shot in
the entire movie and
and so that was wild and it just looks
incredible but like there's
i had to do one that was like a one take
shot and that's my first fight sequence
in the movie
in a bowling alley and that was a lot of
pressure because we had to get that
perfect it's the first one of the movie
and it was just actors no stunt doubles
and so like i felt the pressure of that
so i can only imagine the girls in that
final sequence were feeling the pressure
too
but they're badass they pulled it off uh
if you could have
any of your previous characters join you
in the library
for a fight sequence you know in the
fights uh who would it be and
why i'm going to say
ruby roundhouse from jumanji
if she could join me because because
then we'd have a soundtrack while we
fight which could be fun
i did not think about that but that's
totally true if you could
completely different question if you
could guest star on any tv show
what would you guest star on and why and
same question if you could guest direct
something oh does it have to be a tv
show that's on air right now uh you
could go in the past
friends friends 100 you're a fan
hardcore fan like that's all i watched
growing up
in scotland was just episodes of friends
and i was like i'm going to move to new
york and i'm going to have friends
does this also apply for what you would
guess direct i'd be so scared i don't
know if i could even talk to those
actors genuinely
i think i would just be like
i'm assuming you watched the reunion
then yeah and i made something similar
to that noise
that's great um one of the things about
the film is that um
there is a lot of uh cool aesthetic
colors like the choices of color in the
film are really cool
did you notice all that when you were on
set or like how did you
you know what i mean i did notice some
of it in terms of like the
costumes and the colors chosen for even
like
the body bags were like yellow there was
just all these like interesting choices
around
but i didn't really grasp it in its full
form until i watched the movie because
then i could see the lighting because i
really wasn't you know
seeing the lighting properly as it was
going down the camera uh
and so it's a visual feast i mean
michael the dp has just
nailed it and they've just done some
really cool stuff with color in the
movie
yeah no i'm your your dp's kind of
talented you know
he's okay
i'm underselling what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of the bill
if anything i mean
as violent as it is we were having the
biggest laugh ever
i think just very silly women coming
together and being silly and then it was
like action and it was like looking
badass
but uh very different off camera very
silly a lot of jokes and pranks and
stuff like that
and and i would say that also like you
know this is a slightly
new thing i mean it's not completely new
but like like just seeing
female assassins that do have more like
they're not just
stoic and hard there's like a lot of
emotion going on and they are
like really complex characters and we're
not just getting glimpses of the emotion
we're getting access to
their minds which is something we don't
see as often with
female assassins or assassins in general
so that's kind of cool
i completely agree um uh i am really
looking forward to the
marvel cartoon animated series what if
and
i believe you did a voice or did some of
it i did
can you tease any what can you tease for
that series oh
i can tease that nebula is going to be
very different
in that like a very different visual
and persona have you seen any of the
final episodes or no
no nothing i just remember seeing my
character being like whoa this is a
departure from the nebula that we know
i cannot wait um you are also in the
upcoming thor sequel
um and i'm definitely curious what was
your reaction reading the script for the
first time
uh and what can you tease about it
what can i tell you without telling you
anything basically yes
this is the art form that you have to
master when you're in a marvel movie is
talk without saying a single thing
that's why i often ask people about
reading the script for the first time in
their reaction to it
because it doesn't spoil the movie and
you can you know
get a taste of what you thought my
reaction reading the script was like
excitement
it was like this is going to be a hell
of a ride
it's taika at his best in his most taika
um and yeah i mean the guardians in it
are just i think
hilarious um and also thor
is even more hilarious than he was last
time
i cannot wait do you know have you read
james's script for guardians three um
when what can you say about that and
when do you start filming
i read that script with paul clemente
who plays
mantis we read it together and we both
cried and laughed but there was full
tears
um it's incredible i think it's james's
strongest
work yet um with the guardians and
it's just brilliant it's brilliant and
it's emotional and it's funny and it's
all of those things that you want
i couldn't be more excited listen
congrats on this movie
and i hope that it's a huge hit for you
guys thank you so much